communication à l'université
Panthéon Assas
c'est université qui est encore un nom
français c'est bien ce que l'autre jour
on a fait la économic School business je
sais pas quoi de Rennes
vous avez publié en 2020 les nouvelles
lois du web dans lequel vous détaillez
vos pistes pour assurer une régulation
démocratique des contenus en ligne selon
vous trois principes devraient guider
cette régulation la transparence des
procédures la reconnaissance d'un droit
d'appel et enfin la création d'une
agence publique indépendante chargée de
contrôler l'action des plateformes en
matière de régulation des contenus c'est
un point qui nous intéresse
particulièrement pour faire un peu la
différence avec ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui et pourquoi ça ne serait pas
suffisant ou pas efficient par ailleurs
alors que les 19 plateformes dont Tik
Tok doivent se conformer d'ici la fin du
mois d'août aux obligations imposées par
le règlement européen sur les services
numériques nous aimerions connaître
votre analyse sur ce règlement ces
exigences vous paraissaient suffisantes
et sont-elles applicables et ceux qui
sont chargés de l'appliquer en orient-il
seulement les moyens
enfin plus globalement nous
souhaiterions vous entendre sur les
spécificités si vous êtes en mesure de
nous les caractériser de la politique de
modération de Tik Tok et sur les cas de
censure ou de
fantomisation comme on dit
d'informations de contenu sur
l'application comment est organisé cette
modération en traction des algorithmes
et intervention humaine TikTok a-t-elle
des stratégies pour stopper la viralité
de certains contenus jugés indésirables
et le font-ils et puis nous aurons
probablement d'autres questions et vous
même pourraient préciser les choses
dans votre exposé linéaire avant cela je
dois vous rappeler que l'audition est
captée et retransmise en direct sur le
site du Sénat et comme nous sommes dans
le cadre d'une commission d'enquête je
dois vous rappeler également qu'un faux
témoignage devant la commission est
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434 13 14 et 15 du code pénal et je vous
invite à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité en levant la
main droite et en disant je le jure
merci Monsieur et vous avez la parole
pour votre exposé introductif merci
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
cinétatrice merci pour pour votre
invitation à venir échanger avec vous
aujourd'hui sur cette question de la
régulation des plateformes et de la
modération sur Tik Tok alors pour vous
pour vous dire de d'où je parle
exactement
j'ai travaillé en tant que chercheur en
sciences sociales sur les questions de
modération sur les réseaux sociaux sous
l'angle des conditions d'exercice de la
liberté d'expression sur internet et
dans ce cas je me suis intéressé au
dispositif de modération de de grandes
plateformes comme youtube et Facebook
particulièrement alors je suis pas un
spécialiste à proprement parler de Tik
Tok mais pour préparer cette audition
justement je me suis plongé dans les
dans les documents de la firme et dans
différents différentes données articles
scientifiques que je pouvais avoir à ma
disposition et donc je vais vous livrer
un peu mon regard sur cette question de
la modération sur sur tik l'époque mais
je voulais vous dire avant de commencer
que cette étude elle n'était pas
exhaustive et que c'était mon mon regard
sur ce que les données auxquelles
j'avais pu
accéder alors la première chose que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que lorsque je
me suis intéressé justement à ce
dispositif de modération sur TikTok j'ai
été frappé par les similarités qui
existent entre la modération sur TikTok
et la modération sur Facebook et cela
n'est pas anodin puisque à partir du
printemps 2020
Tik Tok a entrepris une grande réforme
de son dispositif de modération et au
même moment l'entreprise a embauché
d'anciens cadres de Facebook et donc on
peut imaginer que ces embauches sont
contribuées justement à cette à cette
réforme qui suit en bien des points les
les pas de méta et de Facebook en
particulier et la période à laquelle se
fait cette réforme n'est pas anodine on
est au printemps 2020 on est pendant le
premier confinement qui pour Tik Tok a
une période d'explosion des
usages mais aussi de controverse sur la
question de la désinformation sanitaire
sur les réseaux sociaux en général et
sur Tik Tok en particulier et de la même
façon Facebook avait entrepris au
printemps 2017 3 ans plus tôt une grande
réforme également de son dispositif de
modération et qui était lié cette
fois-ci aux auditions de Mark Zuckerberg
devant le Congrès américain à la suite
de l'affaire russe et on voit bien que
en tout cas les les regards que porte la
société sur ces plateformes et les
actions des régulateurs et des pouvoirs
publics peuvent avoir des effets directs
on va reparler du DSA tout à l'heure
mais aussi des effets indirects en
maintenant une pression sur ces acteurs
économiques et en les poussant à ce à ce
à se réformer
alors quand on observe un peu le
dispositif de modération TiK ToK on se
rend compte qu'il est assez similaire à
celui de Facebook mais aussi celui
Twitter ou Youtube mais en règle
générale aujourd'hui les grandes
plateformes ont tendance à s'aligner sur
une espèce de standard de normes
communes de modération qui repose sur
plusieurs éléments d'abord des règles de
publication sur Tik Tok elles sont
appelées les règles communautaires qui
déterminent ce qu'on a le droit de dire
ou pas de montrer ou pas lorsqu'on
utilise l'application et ces règles de
modération à la base elles étaient
privées elles étaient opaques le grand
public n'y avait pas accès elles étaient
destinées aux modérateur de la
plateforme et elles ont été rendues
publiques en janvier 2020 et depuis
cette date elles ont été régulièrement
mises à jour augmenter et préciser alors
assez règles de publication
s'associe différents moyens de les
appliquer le premier c'est
une procédure de signalement donc qui
permet aux utilisateurs de l'application
de pouvoir notifier des contenus qui
leur sembleraient illégaux ou contraire
aux règles de publication mais ça toutes
les plateformes on ce type de procédure
de signalement
un autre élément
central se sont justement les
modérateurs humains qui vont revoir
ces signalements pour prendre la
décision à savoir est-ce qu'on laisse la
vidéo en ligne où est-ce qu'on l'a où
est-ce qu'on la retire
Tik Tok ne communique pas sur le nombre
de modérateurs qu'ils emploie
suivant les différentes sources que j'ai
pu consulter il serait entre 10000 et
20000 alors Tik Tok parle de 40
000 personnes qui travaillent dans la
modération mais quand TikTok quand la
firme annonce de tel chiffre elle
englobe tous les juristes et tous les
les chercheurs en informatique qui
développent aussi des outils
d'intelligence artificielle de
modération donc ce sont pas des des
modérateurs à proprement parler qui qui
passent en revue les les contenus si on
fait une comparaison avec Facebook par
exemple sur facebook facebook annonce 30
000 personnes travaillant dans la
modération pour pour la firme mais en
fait il y a 15000 modérateurs qui
travaillent à la à la au passage en
revue des contenus ceci dit entre 10 et
20 000 modérateurs ça reste quand même
des chiffres plutôt importants par
rapport aux autres entreprises du du
domaine mais pour autant et ça c'est
vrai pour toutes les plateformes la
modération humaine ne suffit pas sur Tik
Tok
l'entreprise a atteint le nombre de
prêts de 2 milliards d'usagers actifs
donc le nombre de contenus est beaucoup
trop important pour être traité
uniquement humainement et comme les
autres plateformes ils ont parié sur
l'intelligence artificielle pour
automatiser la modération c'est à dire
qu'on va entraîner des algorithmes à
partir des bases de données constituées
des vidéos qui ont été retirées par des
modérateurs humains pour que ces
algorithmes apprennent à reconnaître des
contenus
illégaux ou qui contreviennent au
standard de publications
donc depuis 2019 Tik Tok publie des
rapports de transparence tous les
trimestres et dans le dernier rapport de
transparence qui date du dernier
trimestre 2022 la firme faisait état de
85 à 95%
des contenus supprimés qui l'était par
des outils d'intelligence artificielle
donc qui étaient retirés automatiquement
de la plateforme et cette tendance à
l'automatisation sur Tik Tok comme pose
deux types de problèmes
d'une part elles sont facilement
contournables c'est-à-dire que on le
voit par exemple dans le cadre de la
lutte contre les discours de haine
les groupes racistes misogynes
antisémites ou autres
après une très rapidement à déjouer
cette modération automatique par exemple
en utilisant un mot à la place d'un
autre pour ne pas être pour ne pas être
repéré et le deuxième type de problème
c'est que cette modération automatique
elle génère des faux positifs
c'est-à-dire qu'elle va retirer des
contenus qui n'auraient pas dû être tiré
qui était légitime sur la plateforme et
donc Tik Tok communique sur un un taux
de faux positif de 5% ce qui lui semble
suffisamment bas pour généraliser
l'automatisation de la modération mais
si on remet ça en contexte à l'échelle
des 85 millions de vidéos qui ont été
supprimées sur le dernier trimestre ça
représente quand même ces faux positifs
représentent quand même plusieurs
millions de vidéos et donc pour faire
face à ces risques de censure exclusive
Tik Tok comme les autres ont mis en
place des procédures d'appel pour que
les utilisateurs qui jugent avoir été
victimes d'une censure abusive puisse
demander un second examen de de leur
contenu par des modérateurs humains et
puis le dernier élément de ce de ce
dispositif de modération c'est aussi
toute la communication qui entoure cette
modération c'est à dire historiquement
les plateformes ne communiquent pas sur
la modération mais poussé par la société
les régulateurs elle commence à le faire
et TikTok a suivi les mêmes le même
chemin que facebook avec un centre de
transparence sur lequel on peut accéder
à des à divers rapports sur les
pratiques de modération une newsroom
dans laquelle on trouve des actualités
sur les politiques de la firme un centre
d'aide aux usagers et puis des
collaborations avec des organisations de
la société civile diverses et variées
donc tout ça en fait c'est très conforme
aux évolutions et aux tendances
actuelles de la de la modération sur les
grandes plateformes de réseaux sociaux
pour autant il y a quand même deux
spécificités de Tik Tok qui induisent
des particularités dans son système de
modération la première c'est le fait que
les contenus qui apparaissent dans dans
la page d'actualité de l'application la
fameuse page for you ou pour toi en
français qui est la page qui se lance
lorsqu'on ouvre l'application bien sûr
cette page
on retrouve des contenus qui ne sont pas
forcément produits par les contacts que
l'on suit alors ça paraît anodin dit
comme ça mais quand on y pense sur
Facebook sur Instagram ou sur Twitter
les contenus qui apparaissent sur nos
files d'actualité sont ceux qui sont
postés par les gens qu'on a décidé de
suivre avec qui on a noué un contact et
donc ce qui signifie que sur Twitter sur
Twitter sur Tik Tok
l'exposition à l'information ne se fait
pas via des liens d'affinités
personnelles et on y voit les contenus
que l'application nous recommande donc
tout l'enjeu sur Tik Tok de la censure
abusive ou à l'inverse de la
[Musique]
raisonnable on va être ciblé profilé on
va nous nous diffuser du contenu en
fonction de nos profils propres mais
aussi en fonction de certaines
thématiques et là Tik Tok liste un
ensemble de télématiques qui sont exclus
de ces recommandations on y retrouve par
exemple les vidéos qui abordent la santé
mentale celle qui monte des scènes de
sexe explicite ou de violence explicite
celle qui propage de la désinformation
bon tout ça est assez classique en
revanche que ne dit pas TikTok est-ce
qu'on retrouve dans différentes enquêtes
journalistiques et travaux de recherche
dans le domaine c'est que cette
invisibilisation va plus loin
puisqu'elle exclut aussi un certain
nombre de thématiques politiques et
notamment les contenus en lien avec les
droits des minorités
et cela dans des contextes très divers
alors en Chine par exemple tous les
contenus qui concernent les wigours
semble exclus de ce fil de
recommandations mais aux Etats-Unis on a
eu différentes controverses sur le le
mouvement Black lives mat er aussi dont
les dont les contenus semblaient exclus
des recommandations de Tik Tok même
lorsque ces contenus étaient le fait de
de
d'utilisateur très suivi sur ce réseau
social
on a eu le cas de différents mouvements
féministes dans des dans des pays
musulmans notamment en Egypte et puis
des cas concernant la communauté LGBT en
Russie et aussi dans dans beaucoup
d'autres dans beaucoup d'autres pays
la deuxième caractéristique de Tik Tok
c'est aussi que son public est beaucoup
plus jeune que les autres réseaux
sociaux
ce qui pousse à la plateforme à
généraliser un certain nombre de
restrictions à l'accès en fonction de
l'âge et donc à calibrer les publics
exposés aux différentes informations là
aussi sur un critère d'âge assez assez
précis et par exemple depuis l'été 2022
l'application a lancé un système de de
classification des contenus donc des
thèmes abordés sur TikTok auquel est
associé à un score de maturité
c'est-à-dire qu'en fonction du thème que
vous abordez dans votre vidéo Tik Tok va
considérer que ce thème est plus ou
moins mature et donc peut être rendu
visible à différents types de public
alors ce qui peut paraître en soi
légitime lorsqu'on pense au contenu
sexuellement explicite ou violent mais
ce qui peut aussi servir à exercer des
formes de de censure plus ou moins
victime pour le coup et je vais je vais
revenir dessus également un autre point
qui me semble important à souligner
c'est le rapport de Tik Tok au contexte
local
tous les grandes plateformes aujourd'hui
ont mis en place des systèmes de
modération à deux niveaux c'est à dire
qu'il y a des règles de publication qui
s'appliquent à tout le monde donc ce
sont les règles communautaires dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure Facebook a la même
chose Twitter YouTube ils ont tous les
règles internationales qui s'appliquent
à tous les utilisateurs pour autant
les essais de s'adapter au contexte
législatif de des pays dans lesquels ils
exercent et par exemple en France
pendant longtemps sur Facebook
il y avait des règles de modération
spécifiques à la France liées par
exemple aux lois sur les négations des
génocides par exemple qui n'étaient pas
en vigueur aux États-Unis
ou autre et donc Tik Tok adopte la même
approche d'une modération à deux niveaux
pour autant les autres plateformes ont
une approche très légaliste où on
respecte les lois nationales et TikTok
va un peu plus loin en développant une
approche
culturelle alors je vous lis justement
un passage que l'on retrouve dans les
dans les documents de la firme ou Tik
Tok nous dit nous collaborons avec les
experts régionaux et les communautés
locales afin de garantir que notre
approche mondiale reconnaisse les normes
culturelles locales nous adoptons les
applications régionales relatives à nos
règles pour garantir que nous n'imposons
pas les valeurs d'une région à une autre
et donc cette vision d'imposer les
valeurs d'une région à une autre qui
peut là aussi paraître
légitime elle peut aussi servir à des
formes de de censure un peu moins
avouables et en ce semble en ce sens le
Guardian avait révélé en septembre 2019
donc Tik Tok a dit depuis que ses règles
étaient plus en vigueur mais en ayant
accès à des documents internes de la
firme que la firme interdisait de
critiquer les lois et les règles d'un
pays donc on voit bien ce qu'on peut
mettre derrière ce
ce genre de règles d'évoquer aussi les
conflits religieux ouhniques ou encore
le séparatisme avec des exemples qui
touchaient à la fois le Tibet et Taïwan
pour la Chine mais aussi le conflit Nord
irlandais la république de Tchétchénie
en
Russie et aussi de manière plus générale
l'exagération de l'ampleur du conflit
ethnique entre blanc et noir sans qu'on
sache exactement ce que ce que la firme
mais derrière et donc pour terminer mon
propos introductif je voudrais aussi
vous dire que
ce qui est bien important à avoir en
tête c'est que les chercheurs les
régulateurs ou les journalistes qui
travaillent sur ces questions sont
dépendants des données qui sont fournies
par les plateformes ça c'est un point
important c'est à dire que par exemple
tous les toutes les données chiffrées
que j'ai pu vous donner elles sont
tirées des rapports de transparence de
Tik Tok et donc les grandes firmes nous
donnent accès aux données auxquelles
elles veulent bien nous donner accès
[Musique]
chercheurs puisque elle définit un
certain nombre de données auxquelles qui
doivent être rendus publics Tik Tok a
initié d'ailleurs en Europe des centres
de transparence donc qui sont des lieux
physiques dans lesquels des chercheurs
indépendants de la fille peuvent avoir
accès à un certain nombre de données
c'est aussi une des pistes qui est
privilégiée par le digital services Act
mais évidemment tout l'enjeu aujourd'hui
va être dans la dans la mise en œuvre de
ces
de ces nouvelles de ces nouvelles
obligations voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire en introduction
merci Monsieur si Monsieur le rapport
tanti autorise c'est pour la clarté du
débat et pour pas y revenir après vous
venez de préciser que les données
chiffrées que vous avez donné sont issus
des rapports de transparence des
plateformes elles-mêmes mais quand vous
dites que par exemple sur la question
ouigo ça semble exclu sur le réseau en
Chine que pour Black livemater ça serait
la même chose aux États-Unis sans qu'on
ça c'est exactement ça vous le tirez
d'où c'est une des enquêtes de
journalistiques ou des travaux de
chercheurs pour la plupart anglo-saxons
donc effectivement il y a ces données
sur la modération
que seuls les grandes plateformes
possèdent mais pour autant il y a aussi
une forme de contre expertise de la
société civile qui se met en place soit
avec des enquêtes journalistiques ou des
journalistes en accès à des à des
rapports internes qui ne sont pas rendus
public ou alors même des des
organisations de la société civile et
c'est particulièrement vrai des
associations de défense des droits LGBT
ou des mouvements féministes qui vont
faire des formes de
de quelque part d'audit des algorithmes
des plateformes en faisant des tests
pour essayer de voir comment
fonctionnent les algorithmes et qui vont
être capables de produire des données
alternatives donc c'est vrai qu'on a
quand même accès à ce type de données
mais qui sont produites
contre les plateformes en tout cas sans
leurs
qui sont plutôt qualitatifs c'est un peu
comme quand SOS Racisme faisait des des
essais pour voir si dans les boîtes de
nuit c'est rentré ou pas c'est la même
chose c'est un peu la même chose tout à
fait
merci beaucoup de
c'est considérations préliminaires qui
mène
[Musique]
deux ou trois questions pour commencer
vous proposer une instance de régulation
des contenus une un sens de surveillance
de la modération
[Musique]
on se méfie toujours surtout qu'on est
très critiqué là-dessus le législateur
se méfie toujours de créer des nouvelles
des nouvelles
agences pour des tables et tas de
raisons
il y a aujourd'hui la CNIL il y a
aujourd'hui l'arcom et dans d'autres
domaines l'ARCEP mais c'est pas une
organisme de régulation de contenu
est-ce que ça veut dire que vous estimez
que ces agences aujourd'hui n'ont pas
soit le rôle
le périmètre qui serait nécessaire soit
non pas les moyens
quel serait la différence qu'elle serait
ce qu'apporterait et et
après quel critères une autre agence à
la CNIL et à la com par exemple alors
merci de nous poser ces questions ce que
effectivement cette question de l'agence
publique indépendante j'en avais parlé
dans les nouvelles lois du web mais au
moment où j'ai écrit ce livre
l'arcom n'existait pas encore justement
c'était on était encore à l'époque du
CSA et dadopi et donc aucune des deux
agences n'avait le la même la même
couverture et la CNIL du fait de sa
spécialisation sur la question de la
protection de la vie privée et des
données personnelles
traitait aussi de des enjeux
d'algorithmes mais moins sous l'angle de
la modération aujourd'hui je dirais que
ce serait pas nécessaire de créer une
telle agence parce que l'arcom joue ce
joue ce rôle par contre il me semble
important de de penser la manière dont
différents acteurs
ont un rôle à jouer là-dedans c'est à
dire que le fait que les plateformes
modernes les contenus et exerce une
forme de de police de l'expression
ça me semble légitime d'une part parce
que ce sont des entreprises privées donc
elles ont le droit de modérer elles sont
encouragées à le faire donc qu'elle
déploie des dispositifs de modération
pour contrôler ce que en tout cas
surveiller ce qui est dit lorsqu'on
utilise leur service ça me paraît tout à
fait légitime que un droit d'appel soit
généralisé pour que justement face au
cas de censure abusive les internautes
puissent faire valoir leur droit à la
liberté d'expression ça me semble
important mais ça fait partie des des
propositions du DJ tal de service actes
ensuite il me semble aussi nécessaire
que l'arcom bénéficie des pouvoirs de
surveiller la manière dont les réseaux
sociaux exercent leur modération en
ayant accès à un certain nombre de
données qu'il a aussi sont définies dans
le digital service
de la justice quel rôle de la justice
dans tout ça
par exemple dans le cas de méta Facebook
a mis en place il y a quelques années
son fameux conseil de surveillance
d'ailleurs Tik Tok a mis en place une
une instance similaire avec des
personnalités de la société civile qui
joue en quelque sorte le rôle de cours
de cassation enfin on l'a surnommé la
Cour suprême des contenus de facebook
c'est-à-dire que
lorsqu'un internaute fait appel et qui
n'est pas satisfait de cet appel il peut
faire appel à ce conseil de surveillance
pour que soit
rejet son cas alors est-ce qu'il est-ce
que c'est nécessaire de mettre en place
ce genre de de
conseils dans un pays comme la France
c'est pas évident par contre comment la
justice et comment le parquet numérique
par exemple pourrait aussi se
saisir des des controverses autour de la
de la modération ça ça me semble un
point important à définir alors après
évidemment il faut des moyens pour ça
mais on a eu des cas
intéressant en France on a eu des
mouvements féministes qui ont porté
plainte contre Instagram pour pour
censure abusive en demandant justement à
ce que Instagram
rendent public la manière dont les
décisions étaient prises concernant
l'ascension des contenus qui était
incriminés donc qui à la fois de la
modération au sein des plateformes avec
des procédures d'appel une agence
publique qui observe
sans contrôler non plus trop fermement
le ce que font les plateformes et la
justice qui puisse aussi
prendre des décisions ça me semble être
une articulation importante en tout cas
merci bien alors je voudrais poursuivre
un peu sur ce sujet
parce que en définitive ce que vous nous
dites c'est que le DSA est en train de
satisfaire à la demande que vous avez
faite puisqu'il recommande des instances
de surveillance de régulation et à
chaque pays de déterminer quel doit être
cet instant et la France d'ailleurs est
en train de réfléchir est-ce que ça va
être la reconnais est-ce que ça doit
être une autre
je ne suis pas sûr et c'est pour ça que
je vous posais la question je ne suis
pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui nous ayons
quelques sens que ce soit à moins de le
rajouter des
des prérogatives qui satisfassent à
cette qu'ils a déjà notamment à ce que
vous demandiez est-ce que demande le DSA
la CNIL en ce qui concerne les données
elle a condamné un certain nombre de
plateformes et notamment Tik Tok à des
amendes
importantes et elle fait son travail sur
le sur les données
l'arcome sur les contenus
à moins que je sois mal informé
j'attends encore
une intervention de nature sanction ou
de nature injonction ou de nature
dialogue peut-être le lien qui se fait
son qu'on sache mais j'attends encore
et les contenus c'est aussi important
que les données donc est-ce que vous
pensez que l'une de ces instances peut
demain
assurer ce que demande le DSA et ce que
vous souhaitez
est-ce que le
l'expérience de ces instants je vous
parais suffisante ou est-ce que en
définitive vous en revenez à ce que vous
disiez au départ c'est à dire que le DSA
que les souhaits du DSA devraient être
implémentées avec une agence spécifique
non je pense que l'arcom elle est
compétences pour le faire et l'expertise
pour le faire et elle est en train de de
muscler justement cette expertise et
larcome collabore aussi avec pas mal de
de chercheurs dans le domaine pour
réfléchir à des pistes de de régulation
mais sur le cas justement qu'est-ce que
va changer le digital service Isaac à ce
niveau là il y a quand même des pouvoirs
de de
d'amande qui n'était pas qui n'était pas
en vigueur avant et en ce qui concerne
les très grandes plateformes donc celles
qui ont plus de 10 % de la population
européenne qui comme utilisateur
c'est la Commission européenne aussi qui
va qui va prendre en charge cette
régulation avec différentes échelles de
sanctions et des des amendes qui peuvent
s'élever alors si je dis pas de bêtises
je crois que c'est ce chiffre de de 4%
du chiffre d'affaires des plateformes
dans les pays où il y a un problème ce
qui représente des montants importants
pour pour ces plateformes et puis avec
la la comment dire la sanction
ultime qui serait de fermer l'accès du
marché européen aux plateformes qui ne
se conforme pas aux nouvelles règles
alors il paraît peu probable que en
Europe ce type de sanction soit mise en
place mais je pense qu'il ne faut pas
non plus négliger euh
le le l'impact que peut avoir une telle
menace sur les politiques des
plateformes c'est-à-dire que que ce soit
méta Google ou Tik Tok elle réalise un
chiffre d'affaires très important sur le
marché européen donc non aucun intérêt à
se voir restreindre l'accès au marché
européen et elles ont à l'inverse tout
intérêt à se conformer aux nouvelles aux
nouvelles règles en vigueur et en tout
cas elle semble s'y préparer en ce
moment après la question va être de
savoir
tout l'enjeu va être de savoir à quel
type de données le régulateur a accès et
quels sont les conditions d'accès à ces
données ça c'est ça reste encore à
définir il y a différentes pistes qui
sont mises en avant mais c'est vraiment
là que ça va que ça va se jouer
vous parlez d'accès au marché européen
cela
s'opposerait non seulement des organes
de régulation des organes de régulation
nationaux mais un organe de régulation
européen
à votre avis est-ce que ça comment ça
qu'est-ce que vous dites que le DSA
c'est un c'est un acte européen c'est un
acte et par conséquent et il va être là
pour réguler un certain nombre de de
plateformes notamment et
vous dites que l'une des sanctions que
l'on pourrait qui serait envisageable et
qui effectivement
l'épée des mots clés ce serait la
l'interdiction de l'accès au marché
européen mais pour ce faire il faut une
décision européenne conséquent il faut
sans doute un régulateur européen est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une des pistes
qui pourrait être
il me semble que ce sera à vérifier il
me semble que c'est justement prévu par
par le digital service Isaac pour les
très grandes plateformes le nom de cet
instance m'échappe mais avec sur le
modèle de la CNIL un système de de
réseau et coordination de régulateur
nationaux chapeauté par une instance
européenne oui c'est ce qui se fait
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui semble en train
de construire avec l'Irlande qui serait
qui serait pas le régulateur européen
mais qui serait en liaison avec les
différents régulateurs nationaux
sur ce DSA
est-ce que il vous paraît suffisant ou
est-ce qu'il y a que vous auriez des des
suggestions
de choses qui n'y sont pas et qui
seraient importantes à ajouter en termes
de modération de contrôle des contenus
alors le DSA c'est quand même un texte
qui est ambitieux qui est même très très
ambitieux par rapport à ce qui existait
auparavant et moi mon point de vue c'est
qu'on a dit pendant de nombreuses années
que les plateformes étaient plus fortes
que les États
et que elles étaient impossible à
réguler et donc on peut aussi se réjouir
du fait que les les un tournant semble
s'amorcer et que que ce soit aux
échelons nationaux à l'échelle
européenne il y a une tentative de
régulation qui s'affirme ce que demande
le DSA il y a quand même un certain
nombre de de
donner importante en termes de
transparence des dispositifs de
modération en termes de transparence des
algorithmes
comment les algorithmes des différentes
plateformes organisent les contenus ça
ça me semble intéressant mais tout
l'enjeu ça va être aussi de voir comment
tout ça va être mis en oeuvre et quel
type de données vont vraiment être
rendus publics parce que en fait on est
facilement noyé dans l'idée que ces
plateformes pourraient nous livrer des
milliers de données différentes et on ne
saurait pas quoi en faire tellement on
aura accès à un grand nombre de données
alors qu'en fait la régulation des
contenus peut se résoudre en répondant à
une question très simple qui est qui est
exposé à quoi et pourquoi pourquoi deux
usagers de Tik Tok voient des contenus
très différents sur leur fil d'actualité
et quels sont les critères qui vont
déterminer le fait que tel acteur voit
quel type quel type d'information et
donc ça on peut répondre à cette
question avec avec un nombre de données
somme toute limitées donc est-ce que ça
on pourra y avoir accès ça ça me ça me
c'est vraiment une question qui me
semble qui me semble importante le DSF
et d'autres choses qui me semblent
importantes également c'est s'attaquer
aussi au marché de la publicité parce
que même si ça reste limité on pourrait
aller beaucoup plus loin mais toutes les
controverses que nous avons eu ces
dernières années sur la désinformation
la violence en ligne
et sont liés au modèle économique des
plateformes au fonctionnement de leur
régie publicitaire et à l'absence de
contrôle justement de leur régie
publicitaire et au marketing ciblé la
manière dont on va cibler les
internautes pour leur diffuser des
contenus et donc
la question de la régulation de la
publicité en ligne
ça a quand même été un angle mort des
des plans de régulation pendant un
certain nombre d'années et là avec le
DSA il est quand même question
d'interdire le marketing ciblé à
destination des adolescents donc là
c'est plutôt le
je crois que c'est dans le DSA le
marketing Sublet
donc interdire le de cibler des
adolescents des personnes non majeures
et aussi de l'interdiction de cibler les
utilisateurs en fonction de données
personnelles comme leurs opinions
politiques leur préférence sexuelles
leurs origines ethnique etc etc donc là
encore tout l'enjeu ça va être devoir
comment comment il est possible de
mettre ça en place mais si c'est mis en
place ça va dans le bon sens après
comment on pourrait aller plus loin pour
limiter justement ce ciblage marketing
qui fait tant de mal si déjà on met ça
en place ce sera déjà un pas intéressant
ce qui est aussi intéressant c'est dans
le DSA c'est de l'idée de transparence
des recommandations et la possibilité
qui devrait être laissée aux
utilisateurs
de paramétrer soi-même la manière dont
les contenus nous sont recommandés c'est
à dire est-ce que je veux que sur mon
fil d'actualité Facebook
ou Twitter Instagram ou sur ma page for
you de Tik Tok les contenus me
parviennent en fonction de mon de mon
ciblage de mes goûts personnels qu'on
analyse en fonction de mes données
passées où est-ce que je veux par
exemple que elle s'affiche suivant un
critère chronologique et donc que les
plus récentes s'affichent en premier et
donc ça aussi c'est
exigé par le DS comment ça va être mis
en place et c'est encore un enjeu
important mais je veux dire si toutes
les règles qui sont prévues aujourd'hui
sont mises en place en 2024 on aura des
réseaux sociaux qui seront quand même
très différents on aura un pouvoir
redonné aux usagers qui sera lui aussi
différents
et donc tout ça me semble aller dans
dans le dans le bon sens on pourrait
peut-être en rajouter mais je dirais
dans dans par rapport à tout ce qui est
mis en place on va plutôt surveiller la
manière dont tout ça est mis en place
avant de penser à des nouvelles règles
enfin c'est mon point de vue personnel
l'une des spécificités de Tik Tok c'est
l'âge de ces utilisateurs même si ça
change et si ça évolue
non seulement l'âge de ces utilisateurs
qui sont essentiellement des adolescents
et des enfants mais c'est en plus une
absence totale de contrôle d'âge il
suffit de
qu'un enfant de 8 ans dit qu'il a 18 ans
change sa date de naissance il n'y a
aucun contrôle et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
sur la plupart des plateformes ce
problème de contrôle d'âge n'est
absolument pas réglé le DSA
à ma connaissance envisage parmi les
recommandations la mise en place du
système de contrôle d'âge les
plateformes disent c'est un vrai
problème parce que il n'y a pas de
solution soit disant aujourd'hui si
c'est l'État qui contrôle l'âge les
les
ça pose un problème de liberté publique
bien entendu et les startups qui
proposent des
le contrôle avec une double
anonymisation semble ne pas avoir encore
aujourd'hui
être au point aujourd'hui or le DSA va
s'appliquer prochainement
comment voyez-vous le est-ce que vous
voyez une issue à cette contradiction
c'est une question
compliquée et qui est en même temps très
révélatrice des difficultés qu'il y a à
réguler les plateformes et à arbitrer
entre d'un côté
exercer un contrôle public sur le
pouvoir de ces plateformes sur
l'expression et en même temps défendre
la liberté d'expression des des citoyens
que que permettent quand même ces
applications parce que c'est vrai que
malgré tout elle elles sont au service
de enfin elle servent aussi la liberté
d'expression alors sur le contrôle de
l'âge et on est typiquement face à ce
genre de situation ou est-ce que la
solution ne pourrait pas être pire que
le problème c'est à dire que
Tik Tok a proposé de réaliser un
contrôle facial
comme le permet de certains
smartphones pour scanner le visage pour
savoir évaluer l'âge des utilisateurs
mais ce qu'on a envie que des données
biométriques soit rendu accessible à
TikTok de la sorte et stockée
parce que effectivement ils le font
peut-être ils peuvent ils le font
peut-être déjà mais oui en tout cas
qu'il le fasse légalement je suis pas
sûr que ce soit une très bonne idée le
système des tiers de confiance paraît
être
un moindre mal si on propose à des
à des entreprises ou des associations de
jouer ce rôle de tiers de confiance qui
vont assurer de l'âge d'un utilisateur
auprès d'une plateforme et sans que
l'utilisateur n'est à communiquer ces
données privées c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
a été recommandé par le gouvernement
dans sa dans sa dernière loi après
comment ça s'applique pour TikTok ça me
semble ça me semble compliqué avec le
nom d'utilisateurs voilà c'est comment
techniquement c'est possible de le
mettre en place je suis pas la bonne
personne pour vous répondre il me semble
que ça ça pose des défis techniques qui
sont très importants
j'ai oublié de vous dire quelque chose
tout à l'heure sur le service Isaac qui
est important sur est-ce que le texte
est assez ambitieux il y a aussi un une
nouvelle règle qui me semble très
importante c'est le fait que les très
grandes plateformes doivent réaliser des
audits indépendants de leur système de
modération je terminé mon propos
intrusif en vous parlant de la
dépendance des régulateurs et des
chercheurs par rapport aux données des
plateformes là justement ce serait aussi
un moyen de pouvoir certifier que les
données qui sont transmises sont
authentiques et il me semble que c'est
une piste une piste importante je
referme la parenthèse mais
le en définit le contrôle de ces données
le contrôle de la modération
implique d'avoir accès à l'algorithme
pas forcément euh pas forcément en fait
par exemple lorsque vous avez
aujourd'hui accès aux rapports de
transparence de Tik Tok Tik Tok va vous
dire
j'ai des exemples là le dernier dernier
semestre on a retiré 100 millions de
vidéos il y a des graphiques 80 % l'ont
été de manière automatiqueée on a retiré
tant de contenu relatif à la nudité tant
de contenu relatif au discours de haine
donc on accède des données il manque des
données dans ses rapports par exemple on
voudrait savoir comment fonctionne quel
type de vidéo a été exclu de la
recommandation et donc a été
invisibilisé quel pourcentage ça
représente du volume total de vidéo
combien de de est-ce que les les
utilisateurs sont systématiquement
avertis du fait qu'ils font l'objet
d'une sanction donc il manque plein de
de données de ce type mais
même parmi les données qui sont
présentes
Tik Tok nous dit avoir retiré 85
millions de vidéos mais peut-être que
c'est pas vrai en fait on n'a pas le
moyen de savoir et donc ces audits
seraient là aussi pour pouvoir dire ce
qu'on voit dans les dans les sur les
serveurs c'est ça correspond
effectivement aux données qui sont
transmises donc sans sans rendre public
ces données parce qu'évidemment il y a
des enjeux de secret industriels très
important derrière les formules de ces
algorithmes mais pouvoir certifier que
ces données sont authentiques donc ça
veut dire qu'il y a quelqu'un une
instance une
qui est susceptible d'avoir accès à ces
données ou des agences indépendantes de
data mining ce genre de foot de données
ce genre de d'acteurs
une dernière question et puis je
laisserai mes collègues posaient les
leurs
vous nous avez parlé du Shadow banning
[Musique]
en disant ça pose ça pose un problème
comment
est-ce que vous y voyez une d'avoir
est-ce que c'est un problème grave
est-ce que vous y voyez une solution et
est-ce que le DSA est
susceptible de répondre à cette à ce
problème est-ce que dans les articles du
DSI
une solution alors
déjà c'est effectivement un enjeu très
important dont on dont on prend pas
forcément la mesure mais le Shadow
banning donc la l'invis civilisation la
fantomisation c'est quand même un
nouveau régime d'exercices de
l'ascenseur comme on en a pas connu
avant qui repose non pas sur le principe
d'empêcher quelqu'un de s'exprimer mais
de faire en sorte qu'il s'exprime dans
le vide qui parle dans le vide et qu'il
ne sache même pas qu'il parle dans le
vide
et que personne ne le voit et personne
ne l'écoute et ça c'est rendu possible
dans la vraie vie ça existe déjà parce
qu'il arrive qu'il y a plein de
spécialistes sur les plateaux télé qui
sont persuadés qu'on les écoute
alors ça existe déjà
oui peut-être quand même ça existe aussi
peut-être mais on a des des données pour
le coup produit par la société civile
qui montre que ça existe alors comment
ça marche concrètement par exemple sur
sur facebook
imaginons que vous ayez une page d'un
média ou autre et vous êtes suivi par
300000 personnes donc lorsque vous
postez un contenu ce contenu va
s'afficher sur le fil d'actualité
potentiellement de 300000 personnes et
vous avez accès à vos statistiques pour
savoir que en moyenne vos contenus sont
vus par 100 000 utilisateurs et du jour
au lendemain dans vos statistiques vous
voyez que vos derniers contenus ont été
vus par 100 personnes ou 50 personnes
sans que vous puissiez expliquer
pourquoi et donc ce qu'on comprend c'est
que les plateformes parce que justement
elles ont cette position d'intermédiaire
entre ceux qui produisent des contenus
et ceux qui les consonnent peuvent
décider de paramétrer le public de
décider très précisément vous vous allez
voir ça vous vous allez voir ça et ça
vous allez pas le voir
et et donc ça marche comme ça sur
Facebook sur Youtube ou sur TiK ToK on
retire les vidéos des recommandations
c'est à dire que par exemple je vous
parlais du mouvement Black lives matter
aux États-Unis on a des cas de
d'influenceurs TikTok je mets des
guillemets qui faisaient des vidéos
marrantes d'adolescents qui étaient vus
par des millions de personnes du jour au
lendemain après la mort de Georges Floyd
il décide d'aller
de sortir dans la rue pour documenter
les manifestations en les filmant il les
post sur Tik Tok en mettant un hashtag
BMM pour Blacklight metter et là il se
rendent compte que leur vidéo habituelle
qui sont vus par des millions de
personnes bah celles là n'est plus vu
que par 100 personnes ou par mille
personnes et de la même façon ils se
rendent compte que c'est uniquement les
vidéos avec le hashtag black lives
matter ce qui semble indiquer que il y a
une forme de censure algorithmique qui
est de dire si vous utilisez ce mot clé
vous n'aurez pas accès à la
recommandation donc personne ne vous
verra donc ça c'est effectivement un
enjeu très important sur lesquels dans
les rapports de transparence on aucune
information on ne sait pas combien de
personnes ça touche sur quels critères
là il y a le flou le plus total autour
de ces pratiques et le DSA justement ne
prend pas en charge ces questions elle
les prend en charge en parlant de la
transparence de leur recommandation donc
ça effectivement ça fait partie du du
Shadow banning mais s'il n'est pas
précisé que transparence de la
recommandation c'est aussi transparence
de l'absence de recommandation ou de la
de la de l'invisibilisation elles vont
pas d'elles-mêmes communiquer là-dessus
c'est vraiment une pratique qui
aujourd'hui généralisée et et qui sur
lesquels on aurait vraiment besoin
d'informations déjà pour comprendre
l'ampleur du phénomène
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
alors on a parlé du Shadow banning on a
parlé de l'Ascension on a parlé des
algorithmes on n'a pas parlé de
l'inverse c'est-à-dire des pousseurs oui
sur lesquels c'est assez
c'est assez flou
vous dites il y a beaucoup de
renseignements qu'on a pas sur les
centres de transparence etc est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire un mot de cet
usage et est-ce qu'il y a là-dessus une
transparence que pour ma part je n'ai
pas l'impression d'avoir vu non il n'y a
pas transparence là-dessus non plus et
c'est vraiment les les deux domaines
mais qui font partie de la même du même
enjeu qui est comment une plateforme
décide soudainement d'offrir des bonus à
la visibilité énorme à certains types de
contenu et donc aller faire sortir de
l'ombre pour toucher un public
potentiellement gigantesque en tout cas
sur sur Tik Tok
ou comment à l'inverse on décide que ils
n'iront pas accès et que on va faire en
sorte que personne ne les voit donc le
le reach les pousseurs le fait de
d'atteindre un public ça on a on n'a pas
de donner là-dessus on sait pas comment
ça fonctionne
et de la même façon qu'on ne sait pas
comment fonctionne l'invisualisation
donc ça c'est vraiment le un problème
central sur les enjeux de transparence
de ces applications et de ses
plateformes alors je dis qu'on a pas
d'information on en a quelques-unes soit
parce qu'on a des associations qui font
des tests alors par exemple les
mouvements LGBT font plein de tests pour
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on pourquoi on les
censure dans les dans les mots clés
qu'ils utilisent etc
Tic-Toc a quand même communiqué
récemment en publiant les règles
d'éligibilité à la recommandation plutôt
ils ont communiqué sur
les contenus qui seraient inéligibles
donc il y a une liste elle est assez
longue sur qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
fait que un contenu ne va pas être
recommandé alors ça peut être je sais
pas montrer du sang humain ou du
animal la désinformation
voilà dire que le enfin les théories du
complot l'intégrité électorale les faux
engagements la consommation de tabac
l'expo le la nudité voilà donc il y a
tout un tout un ensemble de critères qui
font que si on les publie si on en met
dans nos vidéos on ne sera pas
recommandé
mais la grand enjeu c'est de faire
comment il contrôle tout ça étant donné
le nombre de vidéos auxquelles ils ont
accès parce que Tik Tok a mis en place
des mesures par exemple de lutte contre
la désinformation
en travaillant avec des journalistes
exactement comme l'a fait Facebook
auparavant pour évaluer la la
les la pertinence des contenus
mais ça ça pose deux problèmes c'est
d'abord celui la page où il parle de
désinformation ils disent on va
interdire les théories du complot
lorsqu'on va justement rester en anglais
donc il faut annoncer que un événement a
été
poussé par le gouvernement enfin c'est
très les termes sont très ambigus donc
on se dit mais ça ça pourrait aussi
freiner des lanceurs d'alerte
mais
inversement même si il prétendent
limiter la désinformation on a aussi le
rapport récent de de cette organisation
dont le nom m'échappe tout à coup
et newsgard exactement qui montre que
dans le domaine du covid ou de la guerre
en Ukraine on a quand même accès très
facilement à des contenus qui propagent
de la désinformation je suis moi-même
utilisateur de Tik Tok et pour par
intérêt professionnel et j'ai été très
surpris aussi au début de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine de voir le nombre de contenus
prorus ou de désinformation auxquelles
je pouvais avoir accès sans savoir si
c'était lié à mes intérêts personnels
qui est ton ex m'intéresse à ces
questions là je vais les regarder ces
vidéos là pour savoir ce qu'elle dise et
donc l'algorithme les pousse
spécifiquement j'avais quand même
l'impression mais c'est voilà c'est une
pression que je peux pas quantifier ces
patients typiques mais que on en
trouvait beaucoup est-ce que les études
de newsgard tendent tant à montrer que
c'est
effectivement le cas donc ils font des
règles pour exclure un certain type de
contenu des recommandations à quel point
elles sont pour eux comment elles sont
mis en place est-ce que c'est vraiment
efficace c'est on peut pas savoir voilà
tout simplement
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur pour vos réponses alors vous
avez démarré votre propos tout à l'heure
par rapport à l'arcom notamment et aux
prérogatifs de l'être comme et au moyen
de la com donc il y a un projet de loi
numérique qui arrive
la délégation droit des femmes avait
fait un travail sur l'industrie de la
pornographie avec la proposition
notamment de d'assermenter les agents de
LARCOM et de leur donner un pouvoir
supérieur de sanctions administratives
c'est ce qui va arriver dans le projet
de loi notamment une certaine des
recommandations sont reprises et j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure vous réticences
par rapport aux dispositifs de l'acné et
de pérenne par rapport à ce tiers de
confiance et par rapport au contrôle
d'accès finalement donc moi je j'aurais
envie de vous dire finalement le
contrôle
la reconnaissance faciale ne serait pas
possible le dispositif CNIL pérenne ne
serait pas possible parce que
perfectible
ne doit-on pas finalement avancer même
si c'est pas perfectible pour tenter
quand même de réguler cette cette
industrie sur un deuxième volet de
questions sur la modération les
modérateurs vous avez parlé de
modération humaine et de modération
algorithmiques a-t-on des informations
sur les contenus qui sont supprimés par
l'une ou par l'autre et l'efficacité de
l'une ou l'autre à la fois une
comparaison finalement et en termes de
quantité qu'est-ce que ça représente et
puis cette question quand même à partir
du pas du moment où on parle de
modération des réseaux sociaux des
modérateurs
est-ce qu'il est souhaitable est-ce
qu'il est normal finalement que les
cette industrie
s'autorégulent est-ce qu'on doit pas se
poser la question d'une régulation
extérieure ou d'une plus grande
transparence et ça faisait l'objet des
réponses que vous avez pu déjà ajoutez à
monsieur le rapporteur et sur
l'organisation du flux d'actualité il y
a la possibilité peut-être d'imaginer un
système où ça va être pas être la
chronologie ni l'algorithme finalement
ça va être on va déterminer notre
notre propre algorithme on pourrait
éventuellement imaginer cette solution
la seule chose c'est que est-on en
capacité toute utilité utilisateur
est-il en capacité de
d'élaborer son propre algorithme en
ayant en étant suffisamment éclairé pour
éviter de tomber dans les pièges des
réseaux sociaux et donc à partir du
moment où on se pose cette question quid
d'un réseau social public
quid de son financement quid de comment
on y arrive maintenant parce que le les
réseaux sociaux privés ont largement
pris nos monopole et et
[Musique]
finalement
quel rôle joue quel rôle joue les
monopoles les monopoles pardon
notamment au niveau de Google par
exemple quel rôle il joue par rapport au
pouvoir de ces réseaux sociaux et
comment réussir à inverser ces monopoles
merci pour vos questions alors déjà par
rapport à la au système du de du Tiers
de Confiance là vous me parlez des sites
pornos pornographiques on est d'accord
alors moi je suis pas réticent ce
système de tiers de confiance c'est que
je trouve au contraire c'est c'est
peut-être la meilleure solution
disponible je pense que c'est un bon
moyen de gérer le problème d'avoir un
acteur tiers qui garantit ce qui puisse
garantir l'identité d'une personne mais
sans que
l'application ou le site lui-même
dispose des données personnelles
des internautes que
c'est l'âge pour les oui c'est ça c'est
l'âge pour les les sites porno ou pour
pour Tik Tok pour pour les sites
pornographiques il me semble que c'est
peut-être plus
facile à mettre en place mais encore que
que pour Tik Tok dans le sens où il y a
beaucoup il y a tellement d'utilisateurs
que peut-être que ce sera plus compliqué
donc ma réticence elle était plus dans
la mise en place de ce type de solution
mais je pense que par rapport aux
solutions sur le marché c'est sûrement
une des moins mauvaises
porte d'entrée ma porte dans le sujet du
numérique oui c'est vrai
en tout cas
qu'est-ce qui comment concrètement tout
ça peut être mis en place mais je suis
d'accord avec vous pour dire que c'est
pas parce qu'une solution n'est pas
parfaite qu'il ne faut pas
l'expérimenter ou en tout cas commencer
à avancer alors sur les différents types
de modération en fonction du type de
contenu je vous disais tout à l'heure
entre 85 et 95% des des vidéos sur Tik
Tok sont modérés automatiquement
donc c'est comme quel que soit le type
de contenu la majorité
est modérée automatiquement par des
algorithmes on a une différence suivant
les types de contenu parce que les
algorithmes peuvent être très
performants pour identifier certains
types de contenu comme la nudité ou les
contenus violents parce qu'ils ont été
entraînés sur beaucoup de vidéos
pour les contenus haineux et à plus
forte raison pour les cas de
cyber-harcèlement c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que pour les contenus
haineux c'est facile d'utiliser un mot à
la place d'un autre pour ne pas désigner
la la communauté à laquelle on s'en
prend par exemple et pour le
cyber-harcèlement
la Jet Ski constitue un cas de
cyber-harcèlement est lié aussi au
contexte social dans lequel on part un
échange donc c'est c'est compliqué pour
un algorithme d'être capable de
comprendre ce ce contexte donc
généralement pour toutes les plateformes
c'est la même chose dans le domaine du
cyber-harcèlement il y a quand même
c'est là où on retrouve le plus de
modération humaine mais ça reste quand
même un domaine où la modération
automatique est majoritaire donc ça
dépend des contenus mais dans tous les
cas pour tous les contenus la modération
automatique et majoritaire sur le fait
de paramétrer les algorithmes
vous avez raison c'est à dire que même
si on donne la possibilité aux
utilisateurs de paramétrer leurs
algorithmes et d'ailleurs Facebook le
fait déjà en fait on peut si on fouille
un peu dans les paramètres décider de
l'organisation du fil d'actualité il y a
fort à parier que ils seront très peu à
les utiliser ces possibles mais il y a
deux choses il y a déjà l'important
c'est quand même de laisser ouverte la
porte et de d'offrir cette possibilité
de paramétrage à celles et ceux qui se
sentent concernées par le sujet et après
il y a la manière dont on la rend
possible c'est-à-dire que rendre
possible le paramétrage du fil
d'actualité à travers une procédure un
peu obscure où il faut rentrer dans les
paramètres et au bout de 10 clics
parvenir un endroit où on pourra le
faire ou alors lorsque vous ouvrez votre
fil d'actualité avoir trois options vous
voulez le temps le ciblage ou autre
c'est voilà ça dépend aussi de la
manière dont les plateformes facilitent
c'est possible de paramétrage les et les
rendre visibles et donc là ça dépend
aussi de leur de leur bonne volonté et
pour les réseaux sociaux publics
c'est une question qui se pose parce que
effectivement on a des chaînes de radio
public on échelle de télévision publique
des stations de radio public pourquoi on
n'aurait pas des réseaux sociaux publics
aux États-Unis il y a beaucoup de
recherches dans le sur ces sur ces
questions là à quoi ça pourrait
ressembler alors ce qui ressort de ces
études c'est l'idée de dire qu'un réseau
social public devrait être
ne veut pas forcément dire détenus par
l'État il devrait être à but non
lucratif détenus par des organisations
de la société civile ou des instituts de
recherche c'est c'est conditions
d'indépendance par rapport à l'État
devrait être garantie par la loi comme
pour les radios ou comme pour les
stations de télépubic on pourrait
imaginer que les usagers puissent
participer aussi à la gouvernance de ces
de ces réseaux n'ayant leur mot à dire
sur la manière dont la modération
s'exerce donc on peut très bien imaginer
la manière dont on pourrait fonctionner
des réseaux sociaux publics aux
États-Unis pour les financer avaient été
proposés une taxe minime sur les les
bénéfices des grandes firmes de la de la
tech
la grande question c'est est-ce que ça
marcherait de le faire c'est à dire
est-ce que les usagers se rendraient sur
des réseaux sociaux publics étant
entendu que pour tous les réseaux
sociaux la règle économique qui
s'applique c'est celle de l'effet de
réseau qui veut que on se rend sur
l'application où sont tous nos amis et
où sont déjà les utilisateurs puisque
les contenus étant générés par les
utilisateurs plus il y a d'utilisateurs
sur une appli et plus elle présente
d'intérêt pour les utilisateurs à venir
et donc faire un Instagram public ou un
TikTok public
est-ce que ça rencontrerait un succès on
peut en douter est-ce que ça vaut pas le
coup quand même d'être expérimenté c'est
c'est un sujet un peu différent c'est à
dire que pour selon moi ça vaut le coup
[Musique]
et la situation de monopole et ben c'est
c'est un peu lié à ça effectivement
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où il
y a pas de concurrence
les réseaux sociaux ont un pouvoir
d'autant plus grand que ils n'ont pas de
concurrent direct pour pour
les pousser à agir autrement et de
manière plus transparente et même si il
y a beaucoup de réseaux sociaux en fait
on voit bien qu'entre Tik Tok Instagram
Facebook YouTube twitch Tik Tok
chacun à sa spécificité et propose
quelque chose que nous propose pas son
concurrent et donc ils évoluent sur des
marchés qui sont pas concurrentiels et
donc cette situation de monopole leur
donne un pouvoir énorme mais là aussi la
Commission européenne essaye de lutter
de d'instituer de nouvelles de nouvelles
règles
mais mais oui la situation de sera
jamais satisfaisante tant que il y aura
ces situations de monopole qui
malheureusement risque de perdurer
encore encore longtemps
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
votre exposé vous avez évoqué les
modérateurs humains de Tik Tok alors
j'ai pas bien compris vous avez parlé de
40000 personnes ou de 10000 à 20000
c'est qu'est-ce que c'est ces chiffres
Saiman doux ou cette différence
en anglais donc je sais plus
les nous avons 40000 employés qui
travaillent à la modération chez nous ce
type de formulation ce qui laisse
entendre qu'il y a 40000 personnes qui
sont en train de modérer les contenus
sauf que on peut en douter parce que si
on prend l'exemple de Facebook qui
utilise le même type de formule on sait
que sur les 30 000 personnes qui
travaillent dans le domaine de la
modération chez Facebook en fait il y a
que la moitié de modérateur qui passe en
revue des contenus et l'autre moitié ce
sont soit des ingénieurs qui travaillent
sur les algorithmes de de détection
automatique soit des gens des juristes
qui travaillent sur l'adaptation des
règles ou toutes le personnel un peu
administratif qui travaille dans les
dans les branches publiques polices de
ses compagnies poursuivre parce que
c'est tout un raisonnement je voudrais
savoir si cette modération est
centralisée ou est-ce qu'elle est
décentralisée en fonction des marchés
des territoires
nationaux linguistiques alors sur Tik
Tok je on n'a pas l'information enfin je
n'ai pas trouvé l'information peut-être
qu'elle existe mais
l'information
alors a priori à ce que j'ai cru
comprendre c'est que
j'ai pas trouvé l'information vous leur
posez la question poliment ou alors moi
j'ai pas eu de contact avec Tik Tok
directement mais mais
donc je je
ne saurais pas vous dire de même ou dans
les rapports de transparence qu'il
publie
une communique pas là-dessus on sait que
en Chine par exemple un lanceur d'alerte
qui avait communiqué sur justement la
pression du gouvernement chinois sur la
modération sur Tik Tok parlait de 20 000
employés qui faisaient de la modération
sur le le
sur le
chez le chez Tik Tok mais pour
l'ensemble du du marché international
mais quand on regarde le modèle des
autres plateformes et on peut s'attendre
à ce que TikTok adopte le même le le
modèle classique c'est
de répartir les forces de modération un
peu partout dans le monde non pas en
employant directement des modérateurs
mais en payant des agences ou des des
cabinets de conseils qui vont eux-mêmes
employer des modérateurs dans des
centres de modération alors en France il
y en a pas il y en a à Berlin il y en a
Barcelone qui s'occupe du la modération
du marché français de Facebook par
exemple en tout cas il est sûr que même
s'ils sont en Chine ou ailleurs dans le
monde ils
ont forcément des modérateurs qui
travaillent dans une grande diversité de
langues
je crois avoir vu le chiffre de 60
langues différentes mais il faudrait que
je le vérifie
mais voilà on ne sait pas en gros pour
TiK ToK on ne sait pas et ce serait très
important de le savoir je continue parce
que je fais beaucoup de recherches aussi
sur les données de Tik Tok et c'est
quand même on parle d'absence de
transparence mais on n'arrive pas à
savoir le son le nombre employés dans
cette société alors aux États-Unis il a
été déclaré l'an passé en début d'année
qui avait je crois 5800 salariés Tik Tok
et que l'objectif horizon 18 mois 2 ans
était de 10 000 salariés ça ne compte
évidemment pas les modérateurs puisque
c'est un volume extrêmement important et
quand je fais des extrapolations en
termes de modérateur et d'employés
puisqu'on a quelques chiffres sur l'Inde
sur certains nombre de pays où en Europe
quelques estimations j'arrive à au moins
au global pour Tik Tok or doein à plus
de 50 60 000 personnes quand je regarde
le chiffre d'affaires global
estimé de Tik Tok en 2022 9,4 milliards
de dollars
quand je fais un calcul de ma salariale
surtout quand on va débaucher je parle
pas des petites mains qui font de la
modération mais des ingénieurs notamment
dans la Silicon Valley ou dans le grand
pays européen je m'en sors pas avec une
masse salariale d'au moins 7 huit
milliards je comprends pas je comprends
pas comment cette société gagne de
l'argent c'est la première chose
donc c'est quand même ça reste une
interrogation c'est comment ça
fonctionne parce que des chiffres on a à
peu près des chiffres de volume de
public on a des chiffres de revenus
publicitaires parce que en tous les cas
aux États-Unis en Europe on a des des
évaluations du marché publicitaire de
chiffre d'affaires réellement contrôlés
on sait pas trop nombre d'employés
quelles fonctions qu'est-ce qu'ils font
on ne sait pas enfin il y a quand même
une absence très forte de transparence
et sur la question on parlait des
pousseurs et du reach ce qui est
étonnant quand on tape Google dans
toutes les Google pardon Tik Tok dans
toutes les langues et on cherche
marketing business model on a des pages
de Tik Tok qui est
tic-tac for business ou en gros on nous
explique comment on va valoriser notre
entreprise généralement taille moyenne
sur Tik Tok par l'entremise d'agence qui
sont toutes les Tik Tok et qui à mon
avis faut pas ça gratuitement donc il y
a une partie de la ressource quand même
qui s'évapore la ressource publicitaire
pas très élevée sur Tik Tok puisque les
formats ne permettent pas de mettre trop
de publicité sinon on a un décrochage du
public donc tu sais quand même pour moi
un mystère et une absence totale de
transparence avec un autre phénomène
qu'on voit monter aux États-Unis très
très rapide c'est la mise en chantier de
ce qu'on appelle me to marketing c'est
les moneytes ou en gros
dans la crainte d'une éventuelle
interdiction de restriction on monte
réseau qui ressemble beaucoup à Tik Tok
quelques petites différences et on prend
les influenceurs les plus célèbres de
Tik Tok pour les transférer sur ce
nouveau système là encore ça posera
encore la question de quel
réglementation quel suivi enfin on a
l'impression qu'il y a une course de
rapidité et tout ça dans une logique
dont je vois pas du tout la rentabilité
commerciale économique en tous les cas
sur les premières années j'ai
l'impression que cette entreprise
dépense plus d'argent qu'elles n'ont
rapport donc et surtout ces questions de
modération parce que ça fait du monde
même si on utilise du éventuellement du
netlive pour faire ça et puis de
l'intelligence artificielle vous savez
quand même beaucoup beaucoup de de
dépenses sans compter des dépenses
technologiques donc si c'est un grand
questionnement j'imagine que vous n'avez
pas la réponse mais non j'ai pas la
réponse c'est vrai que les les contenus
enfin les volumes sont importants alors
le fait de dépenser plus d'argent qui
n'en gagne c'est un modèle aussi
classique dans le monde de de la tech et
c'est il y a l'enjeu pour Tik Tok c'est
d'atteindre la plus grande masse
critique d'utilisateurs pour après
comment commencer à monétiser les
contenus par la publicité ce qu'ils ont
quand même commencé à faire plus qu'il
ne faisait à ces derniers temps c'est
aujourd'hui il de la publicité
de manière plus importante sur Tik Tok
qui a qui a deux ans il y a aussi le le
fait de pouvoir permettre aux
utilisateurs de verser des tips des
pourboires aux utilisateurs aux
créateurs qu'ils aiment bien
il y a aussi des comment dire des
partenariats avec des marques qui vont
mettre en avant certains types de
contenu ou alors des marques qui vont
travailler avec des influenceurs sur Tik
Tok et Tik Tok prenant une marche donc
ils ont de ce que j'avais compris il y
avait une vraie diversification des
modèles économiques est-ce que
se diversification elle seule peut
expliquer de tel montant ça je saurais
absolument pas vous le dire par contre
ce qui est intéressant aussi dans ce que
vous dites c'est le on voit bien à quel
point on a accès à aucune donnée alors
que n'importe quelle entreprise qui
aurait un milliard de clients serait
soumis à des normes de transparence
beaucoup plus importantes il chercheuse
américaine qui s'appelle zeembe to fexhi
qui en fait compare le monde de la
technologie aujourd'hui à l'industrie
automobile de au début du 20e siècle
elle dit en fait quand au début du 20e
siècle quand l'industrie automobile
c'est a connu un grand bout mais il y a
pas de ceinture de sécurité il y avait
pas d'airbag il y a pas de code de la
route et en fait c'est la société et
c'est représentant qui ont légiféré pour
imposer des nouvelles règles et elle
elle dit voilà on en est un peu à ce
moment là dans l'histoire de ces réseaux
sociaux c'est à dire que ils ont
complètement explosé on s'est rendu
compte que on a pas d'information on n'a
pas de on a pas de règles qu'on leur
impose et là on est dans le moment
justement un peu historique où on est en
train de de leur imposer des règles
qu'elle n'avait pas mais pour Tik Tok en
tout cas ça paraît quand même assez
incongru de pas être capable de pouvoir
répondre à ces questions là alors que ce
sont des questions basiques sur comment
vous gagnez de l'argent
que qui sont vos employés qu'est-ce
qu'ils font etc enfin n'importe quelle
entreprise
communique un minimum là-dessus donc ils
vont être obligés j'imagine d'y passer
en tout cas
dans une audition qu'on a faite des
sociétés d'auteurs on nous dit Tik Tok
ne s'acquitte pas des taxes vidéo des
taxes sur la publicité donc ça quitte
méta dans sa kit aujourd'hui YouTube
c'est une économie infime que de ne pas
payer ses taxes au regard des dépenses
qui sont faites c'est une façon de dire
nous n'acceptons pas cette forme de
régulation et de se rendre suspecte
d'ailleurs dans dans ces procédés c'est
un petit peu étonnant et c'est vrai que
pour tout le monde et des responsables
de cette société nous a dit moi je suis
négocié avec une entreprise je sais pas
négocier avec le Parti communiste
chinois un peu en terme de en disant je
ne vois pas la rationalité qu'il y a
dans la conduite de cette entreprise
d'un point de vue entrepreneurial et
c'est des questions que qui semble se
poser moi je crois pas du tout qui est
40000 quand même modérateurs parce que
c'est même s'il y a des milliards de
d'utilisateurs des peut-être des
dizaines de milliards de vidéos
je c'est une course à l'échalote que de
vouloir contrôler manuellement je crois
que effectivement il y a une
systématisation
quasi totale
de la modération
je suis d'accord avec vous
alors les journalistes qui enquêtes sur
le sujet disent entre 10 et 20.000 donc
c'est déjà moins mais c'est déjà ça
représente quand même beaucoup mais ce
qui serait intéressant c'est à dire
qu'ils sont ces gens sur quel marché ils
travaillent quelle langue il maîtrise
combien ils sont payés aussi à quel type
de conséquences ils sont exposés à
modérer à les contenus sur Tik Tok et ça
effectivement on n'a pas il y a pas
d'informations
auriez-vous un élément que que vous
n'avez pas eu l'occasion de porter notre
connaissance dans l'échange ou
aviez-vous en vos propres liminaires et
par la suite non je crois je crois qu'on
a passé en revue pas mal de questions et
j'aurais aimé pouvoir vous en dire plus
moi aussi mais c'est vrai que que les
données
de mes collègues sont limités c'est en
soi une réponse à l'interrogation
oui j'imagine j'imagine bien merci merci
Monsieur merci chers collègues